for most of human history relationships
were relatively simple for a banal yet
immovable reason
it was extremely hard to meet anyone
acceptable and everyone knew it
there were only a few people in the
village travel was expensive and social
occasions few and far between this had
many drawbacks
it encouraged people to accept offers
from suitors they were unconvinced by it
meant that characters who would have
delighted each other died lonely and
unfulfilled because there were a few
mountains or a river between them
our technologists have used their genius
to correct these historic obstacles and
provide us with unending choice
meeting someone new is now a constant
possibility
but this breakthrough at the level of
introduction has obscured an ongoing
challenge at the level of ultimate
purpose
we may have become easier to meet but we
are not any easier to love
we remain each one of us highly
challenging propositions for anyone to
take on
all of us are riddled with psychological
quirks that serve to render an ongoing
relationship extremely problematic
we are impatient prone to making unjust
accusations
rife with self-pity and unused to
expressing our needs in a way they can
be understood by others
just to start the list
that we can meet so many people has
beautifully obscured our ugly sides
breeding in us the charming yet
misleading idea which engulfs us anytime
we hit difficulties
that we are in trouble because we have
not until now met the right person
the reason why there is friction and
longing has we tell ourselves nothing to
do with certain stubborn infilicities in
our own natures or paradoxes in the
human condition as a whole
it is only a matter of needing to hunt
further for a more reasonable candidate
who will at last see things our way
the promise of choice has drained us of
the patience and modesty necessary to
grapple with the tensions that are prone
to come our way whomever we might be
with
we forget that almost everyone is a
charming prospect so long as we know
nothing about them
part of what it takes to be ready for
love is to imagine the difficulties that
we cannot as yet know too much about in
detail
the bad moods that will lurk behind the
energetic smiles the difficult pasts
that lie beneath the lustrous eyes
the tangled psyches that reside beneath
a stated love of camping and the
outdoors
even though there are hundreds of other
people we might meet there are not in
truth so many people we could really
love
dating apps may have made it infinitely
easier to connect but they haven't
helped us in any way to be more patient
imaginative forgiving or empathetic
that is any more adept at the arts that
make any one relationship viable
most of the issues we experience with a
given candidate will therefore show up
in comparable guises with almost anyone
we might stumble upon
the real work we should be doing isn't
once we have had a reasonable look
around to keep trying to meet new people
it's to get to the root of what makes it
hard to live with any one person we
could alight upon
we will be ready for love when we
surrender some of our excited sense of
possibility and recognize that though we
might have many choices
we don't in reality
have so many options
it may sound dark but this will in its
own way be a liberating realization that
can help us redirect our energies away
from the exhausting circuit of new
encounters towards a search for the kind
of mutual emotional maturity on which
true love can one day be built
great dates are made up of great
conversations
our dating cards are designed to spark
insightful and playful encounters
click the link on screen now to find out
more